this is all about the astonishing
agility that Givens show as they swing
amid the Viney tendrils of the Borneo
jungle but before you swing you've got a
powerup a fresh fruit snack will do
nicely
and fruit doesn't get any fresher than
this right off the tree and right down
his chest as you can see these Gibbons
are very agile there's even a word to
describe what's happening right here
if one given were to invite another to
swing from tree to tree he might say hey
you want to go brachiating Gibbons have
been known to leap 30 feet in a single
jump to break the eight like a Gibbon
you'd have to become arboreal meaning
light Gibbons you'd have to live in
trees sorry that's just the way it is